à séville bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nouvelle journée de
manifestations un peu partout en france
contre l'obligation vaccinale à paris
notamment une mobilisation qui aura lieu
devant le ministère de la santé qu'est
ce que vous attendez précisément de
cette nouvelle journée de manifestation
aujourd'hui
et nous attendons alors non pas la
suspension de la loi bien sûr mais nous
attendons à ce que ce pass sanitaire
obligatoire pour tous les soignants soit
remis en question parce que nous étions
l'année dernière au front
on est coupé allez-y je vous en prie
donc voilà nous sommes nous avons été
l'année dernière offrant
101-101 moyens matériels sans moyens
humains et nous continuons à y être et
cette année nous sommes mis à
stigmatiser comme des mauvais soignants
et parce que parce que certaines d'entre
nous est très peu parce que nous sommes
quand même pas mal vaccinés ne seraient
pas vaccinés donc nous allons encore
mettre notre secteur déjà très en
difficulté encore plus en difficulté et
ça ce n'est pas entendable pour nous
quoi justement vous vous le dites vous
même vous êtes beaucoup de soignants à
avoir déjà été vaccinées un certain
nombre refuse encore
vous avez sûrement discuté avec eux
peut-être soit sont-ils réfractaires à
cette vaccination
parce que d'une part on nous l'a imposée
sans nous laisser le temps de vraiment
réfléchir parce que parce qu'on nous a
ni
face à une réalité en me disant c'est à
cause de vous que les soignants que les
patients les résidents sont en danger et
pour certains ce n'est pas entendable
parce que l'année dernière ce n'était
pas à cause de nous que les patients et
les résidants étaient en danger
et donc si vous voulez cette fois ci on
peut pendant ce genre d'argument nos
partenaires et nous nous nous soignants
sont en souffrance depuis plus de deux
ans ça fait presque trois ans que nous
dénonçons des conditions de travail
déplorables à l'hôpital et là on serait
en train de faire croire au pays que
c'est nous qui mettons en danger la
population et ça c'est pas entendable
voilà devant cette obligation vaccinale
eu deux maigres à cause de ça encore
d'aidés soignants vont être en
difficulté délivrant fermé et nous
allons le gouvernement va faire reporter
la faute sur nous ce n'est pas
entendable ne soigne un peu plus sur le
terrain alors le ministre de la santé la
décision complètement désastreuse que le
ministère a appris et le ministre a pris
quand vous dites désastreuse est ce que
vous vous craignez voilà deux d'avoir
des problèmes en terme d'effectif on
sait que olivier véran justement retardé
l'obligation nationale dans les
métropoles aussi on risque d'avoir le
même cas
au café on a déjà nous avons passé déjà
lutté dans des conditions très
particulières il manquait des effectifs
partout certains services sont fermées
certains services d'urgence continuent à
fermer par manque d'effectif et donc ça
va faire qu'aggraver les conditions de
travail de douze salariés et ça ce n'est
pas entendable
ce n'est pas entendable alors l'hôpital
qui vous l'avais dit en souffrance
depuis plusieurs années en termes
d'effectifs de moyens de l'y la crise
sanitaire également et vous avez
toujours été au front est ce que
aujourd'hui cette obligation vaccinale
risque voilà de créer une sorte de
rupture entre le gouvernement et les
soignantes
et bien sûr parce que c'est ça va à
l'encontre de ce que nous demandions une
bayonnaise ouverture de poste et nous
devrions des ouvertures de lits et là on
nous oblige à une loi qui veut oublier à
certains salariés déjà qu'ils ont
commencé à à partir certains salariés
ont démissionné de son bien
indisponibilité
tellement les conditions de travail
étaient déplorables et tellement cette
loi les mettez en souffrance donc si
vous voulez l'obligation vaccinale même
si nous ne sommes pas contre le vaccin
mais nous sommes contre cette façon de
faire que nous ne pourrons plus accès t
ce n'est plus acceptable
nous travaillons à flux tendu tout le
temps et en faisant travailler deux fois
plus étendu votre syndicat la cgt
s'inquiète d'une possible catastrophe
sanitaire vous en pensez quoi
mais je suis totalement aussi inquiète
que mon syndicat voilà il ya des
services qui sont inquiets qu'ils sont
complètement difficulté qui n'ont plus
de personnel et puis ça n'impacte pas
que les soignants ça va impacter toutes
eu toute une catégorie de professionnels
qui travaillent dans un hôpital n'est
pas d'une mince c'est toutes les
structures qui sera impacté ce ne sont
pas que les soignants
parce que derrière nous il ya tout le
reste du personnel et ça c est ce assez
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut entendre cette
loi elle et elle est faite pour tous qui
sont en
contact direct avec le patient et
l'usager alors les personnes qui sont
réfractaires justement à cette
vaccination obligatoire les personnels
de santé certains disent qu'ils sont
voilà prêts à quitter leur métier et à
faire autre chose est-ce que vous avez
autour de vous voilà des personnes qui
sont justement prête à ne plus
aller en établissement déjà j'en ai
trois qui ont fui les disponibilités je
travaille dans un centre hospitalier à
muret et pourtant nous sommes vaccinés à
96 87 %
je sais que au chu de toulouse par
exemple dans ma région il y en a aussi à
paris c'est pareil dans certains
hôpitaux certains sont proches sont
prêts à prendre une disponibilité ou
démissionner de leurs 2 lors de leur
emploi pour pouvoir effectivement un ne
pas se faire vacciner
voilà merci l'europe etc ou en tout cas
c'est vrai nous avons pourtant
voilà nous avons pourtant essayé de les
accompagner tous ses salariés nous
essayons de les accompagner au mieux
mais mais ce n'est pas nous qui allons
porter l'entière responsabilité de de
7,7 loin il faut il faut que le
ministère entend que ce soit en
souffrance voilà merci à vous merci
onze d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes tenus secrets
tard santé et l'action sociale de la cgt